et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Franck Riester merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous bonjour et d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ministère j'ai des
relations avec le Parlement on est
ensemble pendant un peu plus de 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
on va évidemment parler de la réforme
des retraites au lendemain de cette
dixième journée de mobilisation
Elisabeth borgne hier soir a invité les
syndicats Matignon la semaine prochaine
est-ce qu'elle est prête à rediscuter de
cette réforme des retraites c'est
d'abord le film n'a jamais été rompu
avec les syndicats et je crois que c'est
une bonne chose que elle puisse
échanger avec les syndicats sur tous les
sujets qui souhaiteront échanger et sur
la réforme des retraites sur tous les
sujets évidemment notamment sur les
sujets qui ont été évoqués ou qui ont
été mis en lumière à travers cette
réforme des retraites sur le travail la
qualité au travail la pénibilité les
reconversions mais aussi tous les sujets
qui seront amenés à être discutés
non le soleil ce point là c'est le cœur
de la réforme sur lequel depuis le
départ il n'y a pas d'accord
il y a dans la vie il y a des moments il
faut savoir que reconnaître aussi des
sujets on n'est pas d'accord donc ils
sont parlés sur les sujets sur lesquels
on est d'accord et pas de se focaliser
sur le sujet on n'est pas d'accord
c'est le c'est le cœur de la réforme
mais ce que demande les manifestants
aujourd'hui c'est justement de
rediscuter de cette mesure d'âge donc ça
c'est pas
un processus parlementaire il y a eu une
présentation d'un texte une discussion
texte des votes une loi adoptée et donc
maintenant ce qu'il faut voir c'est de
quelle manière sur cette loi on peut
travailler dans le cas d'un agenda
social avec les organisations syndicales
avec toutes celles et ceux qui ont envie
de d'améliorer un certain nombre de
choses dans le monde du travail qui
permet justement à nos compatriotes de
mieux travailler d'être dans des
conditions de travail meilleures de
mieux peut-être tenir compte de la
pénibilité de regarder de manière très
concrète comment sera mis en oeuvre
notamment vous savez qu'il y a une loi
et ensuite il y a des décrets
d'applications discuter beaucoup de ces
éléments là avec les organisations
syndicales en tout cas je pense que
c'est bien de pouvoir se parler discuter
et changer vous avez plutôt discuter de
la loi travail à venir que de la réforme
des retraites actuelles vous verrez ce
que ce que fera la première ministre
avec les organisations syndicales c'est
pas moi qui vais là vous dire
on a parlé de ça une heure ils vont
parler de ça simplement le dialogue la
discussion l'échange la rencontre le fil
n'a jamais été on peut mais je pense que
c'est bien dans ce moment particulier de
le faire Laurent Berger dit qu'il va
reparler de sa proposition de médiation
qu'il a fait hier pour lui c'est une
solution pour sortir de la crise est-ce
que vous n'avez pas fermé la porte un
peu trop tôt mais une médiation c'est
utile quand il y a pas de dialogue mais
quand il y a un dialogue et des
discussions il y a pas besoin de
médiation et là il y a un dialogue il y
a des discussions et sur la même chose
puisque vous dites on va pas dialoguer
du cœur de la réforme Laurent Berger et
l'Inter syndical veut dialoguer de la
question du report de l'âge
ne tentons pas de mettre une pression
sur les uns et sur les autres sur leur
position sous-cutative laissons discuter
la Premier ministre avec les
organisations syndicales moi je vous
m'interrogez sur les 64 ans je vous dis
que c'est le cœur de la réforme et que
c'était l'élément qui permet le retour à
l'équipe s'il y a plus de 64 ans il y a
plus de retour à l'équilibre et donc il
y a plus de réforme en revanche et
franchement il partir du moment dans les
dialogues sociales dans les dialogues
parlementaires dans la vie ou il y a des
choses sur lesquelles on n'est pas
d'accord bon voilà donc parlons de tout
ce sur quoi on pourrait être d'accord ce
qu'on peut avancer ce sur quoi on peut
améliorer notamment le les la qualité de
de travail de nos compatriotes vous
dites que le derrière n'est pas rompu
avec Élisabeth borne en effet il va y
avoir cette réunion en revanche le
président de la République lui n'a pas
souhaité recevoir les syndicats est-ce
que le dialogue est rompu avec Emmanuel
Macron il est syndicats le dialogue
n'est absolument pas rompu avec
l'exécutif dans son ensemble là Isabelle
borne recevra les organisations
syndicales et franchement les recevoir
il y a une dizaine de jours et les
recevoir aujourd'hui
vous savez une chose après l'autre là il
y a un moment d'échange
très important entre les organisons
sankales et la première ministre les
sons se passer ce moment-là et
n'essayons pas de trop
vous êtes dans votre rôle vous essayez
décrypter comprendre
le président de la République n'est pas
souhaité recevoir les syndicats
[Musique]
il faut pas les prendre pour ce qui sont
pas ils comprennent ce qui se passe il
voit qu'il y a une volonté de
distribution de dialogue avec les
organisations syndicales de l'exécutif
et ce qui est démontré avec cette
rencontre avec les organisations
syndicales et n'y voyait pas plus ils
comprennent peut-être pas quand on
discute pas de la réforme des retraites
à laquelle ils sont posés mais ils
comprennent très bien que dans une
grande démocratie colanote il y a des
institutions et qu'il faut respecter les
institutions et ces institutions
notamment elles permettent que un texte
proposé par l'exécutif par le
gouvernement soit débattu au Parlement
il y a eu 175 heures de débats il y a eu
un vote de la de du texte d'abord en
première lecture au Sénat il y a eu
ensuite un compromis une CMP c'est
issus du Parlement avec beaucoup de
modifications du texte par rapport à ce
qui était au départ l'idée du
gouvernement ce texte a été ensuite ce
compromis était voté au Sénat et vu
l'incertitude nous avons pris une
responsabilité nous avons fait adopter
ce texte voilà il y a un processus
maintenant c'est au Conseil
constitutionnel et les Français ils
veulent pas qu'on réécrive l'histoire et
qu'on revienne au début de ce que ce
processus là un dernier mot sur la
médiation puisque le modèle alors
Olivier Véran on l'a dit à claquer la
porte assez vite mais le modem lui c'est
dit favorable à cette médiation est-ce
que la majorité est en train de se
diviser non mais j'étais vous savez je
déjeunais avec Jean-Paul Mattei pour
vous dire les choses il y avait du
groupe à l'assemblé exactement et les
choses sont très claires ils veulent
aussi du dialogue et c'est très bien ça
tombe bien la première ministre reçoit
les organisations syndicales en début de
semaine pour discuter dialoguer
alors hier nouvelle journée de
manifestation en France la mobilisation
est en baisse est-ce que ça vous donne
de l'espoir pour la suite des choses
manifestement il y en aura une jeudi
prochain nous on regarde pas comme
certains de mes collègues disent la
météo des manifestations et la météo de
la mobilisation nous ce qui on se
concentre sur une chose c'est d'abord
faire en sorte de reconnaître que il y a
un certain nombre de manifestations qui
se déroulent dans le calme et le respect
notamment grâce au travail des
organisations syndicales et il y a
malheureusement un certain nombre de
d'éléments ultra-violents qui depuis un
certain temps viennent se joindre dans
ces manifestations créer les conditions
de violence son violent avec les forces
de police et gendarmerie et casse pour
simplement vouloir mettre une pression
inadmissible dans une grande démocratie
comme la nôtre je rappelle qu'il y a eu
175 blessés chez les les forces de
police et gendarmerie hier
lors de la manifestation c'est pas
acceptable vous savez je crois que dans
une démocratie comme la nôtre on doit
pouvoir manifester dans le calme sans
que des éléments perturbateurs viennent
mettre la pression sur les
manifestations et sans que des forces
politiques cautionnent ces violences
Franck moi j'étais très choqué de voir
les députés et les filles pardon mais
c'est important de le dire
à sainte-solin ce qui s'est passé à
Sainte-Soline le week-end dernier comme
je suis très choqué de voir que beaucoup
de responsables notamment de la France
insoumise ne disent rien ne dénonce pas
de condamne pas ces violences et ainsi
crée les conditions d'une acceptation de
l'Alliance
quand même oui enfin quand on appelle
pas au calme quand on va soutenir des
manifestations illégales et dans
lesquelles c'était évident ça avait été
dit il allait avoir des casseurs c'est
pas comme ça qu'on fait en sorte
pour les parlementaires qui étaient
présents à Sainte-Soline
je dis très clairement politiquement
c'est inacceptable que les élus de la
République aillent dans des
manifestations illégales dans lequel on
s'est pertinemment qu'il va y avoir des
violences qui mettent en danger la vie
de toutes celles et ceux un qui
protègent nos compatriotes c'est-à-dire
les forces de police et de gendarmerie
et éventuellement même les manifestants
eux-mêmes j'allais dire tout à l'heure
ce qu'on entend beaucoup dans les
manifestations aujourd'hui c'est des
gens dire on a manifesté calmement
pendant des semaines et le gouvernement
n'a pas voulu amender son texte
aujourd'hui qu'il y a des violences les
syndicats sont reçus à Matignon est-ce
que c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire
j'imagine que vous partagez pas ce point
de vue mais est-ce qu'il y a une
concomitance en effet entre la montée de
ces violences et le fait que le
gouvernement renoue le dialogue non mais
d'abord je dis pas on nous parle dont je
ça je peux pas laisser passer ça on a
toujours eu un fil de dialogue
d'échanges et de discussions que ça a eu
dans la préparation du texte Olivier du
socle la première liste ont passé des
heures et des heures à recevoir les
organisations syndicales
ils ont tenu compte de ces rendez-vous
pour modifier le texte par rapport à ce
qui était l'idée au départ quand on a
présenté le texte c'est un texte qui a
tenu notamment compte de ces échanges et
pendant tout le débat parlementaire la
porte on l'a dit moi je l'ai dit sans
arrêt nous l'avons dit sans arrêt la
porte de d'Olivier du socle de la
province est ouverte le fil n'a jamais
été rompu donc ne disons pas qu'on
renoue le dialogue simplement il y a un
moment il y a des étapes là on a une
étape où il faut aussi préparer l'avenir
le prêt à la République a demandé à la
première ministre de réfléchir à la
façon dont on allait proposer un
problème un plan d'action une feuille de
route avec les priorités fixées par le
prix en de la République en travaillant
avec les forces politiques les forces
syndicales avec les élus locaux avec les
français pour voir comment oui oui on va
y venir mais donc et notamment sur ces
questions de plein emploi sur ces
questions de travail sur ces questions
de mise en oeuvre de la réforme d'un
traite tout ça doivent être pouvoir être
discutés en fait pour finir sur les
violences vous parliez des violences des
manifestants il aussi un certain nombre
de violences de la part des forces de
l'ordre une pétition a déjà recueilli
100 000 signataires pour dissoudre la
brave m est-ce qu'elle pourra être
débattue dans l'hémicycle à l'Assemblée
nationale ça nous verrons mais c'est ce
qui est en tout cas par exemple ça
dépendra de quel critère la façon les
choses évoluent mais ce qui est certain
c'est que c'est
s'il y a des actes qui sont
répréhensibles de la part des forces de
policiers de gendarmerie l'IGPN est
saisie et peut y avoir des des suites
administratives ou éventuellement
judiciaires mais n'inversons pas les
choses on peut pas dire qu'on vous
disiez manifestation parfois Pacifique
oui parfois non quand vous avez des gens
qui viennent avec des boules de pétanque
avec des barres de fer avec des masques
qui lancent des projectiles comme on l'a
vu sur les images soit de sainte Soline
soit parfois encore dans les
manifestations les dernières
manifestations c'est inacceptable et il
faut dire que et remercier et saluer le
courage
l'abnégation et la et l'engagement de
ces forces de police
protéger nos compatriotes qui sont
autour des manifestations et au compte y
compris ceux qui sont dans les
manifestants c'est pas suffisant pour
débattre d'une pétition à l'Assemblée
nationale on regardera d'une façon très
précisée chose mais vous savez le débat
il est en permanence
dans les QG on a
d'abord il y a des règles pour un
certain nombre de procédures à
l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat on va respecter les règles en
même temps le débat est ouvert donc les
on est dans un pays dans une grande
démocratie où tous les sujets peuvent
être abordés celui-là en particulier
de parlementaire sur cette question du
maintien de l'ordre c'est une bonne
chose et la France insoumise qui a déjà
manifestement du déjà trois tirages sur
sa commission d'enquête bon on verra si
elle peut le pour l'avenir en faire une
c'est chacun un groupe peut le faire
chaque groupe mais c'est pas une
question j'ai pas jugé la décision des
groupes politiques dans leur commission
d'enquête sur le plan législatif
justement Elisabeth burn a rencontré
hier Gérard Larcher et Gaëlle brune
Pivet que s'est-il dit pendant cette
rencontre c'est une des discussions
entre eux et je ne suis pas l'habitude
de sur une méthode sur un calendrier
j'étais pas avec avec
le ressource la discussion avec le
président des gens parlementaires on va
laisser les discussions entre la
première ministre et le président du
Sénat et la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale de côté ce qui est certain
c'est la volonté de dialogue des
discuter d'échanger de voir comment on
peut organiser le travail parlementaire
sur les priorités que la première
ministre donnera pour faire en sorte que
le travail soit le plus facile possible
pour que les parlementaires et le plus
de temps possible pour travailler en
amont du passage des textes dans
l'hémicycle qui puisse y avoir peut-être
des textes plus courts sur lesquels ils
puissent mieux contribuer que des fois
des grands textes cathédrales qui sont
compliquées à travailler sur tout s'il
n'y a pas suffisamment de temps pour le
faire vous savez majorité pour les voter
alors la majorité pour la voter oui bien
sûr et c'est tout le travail d'ailleurs
qui est en partie le mien le travail du
gouvernement de faire en sorte avec la
majorité de trouver des partenaires à
l'Assemblée nationale au-delà de la
majorité présidentielle pour voter les
textes mais je rappelle que sur deux
solutions par exemple a été évoquée si
on va parler de la dissolution après
mais je voudrais le finir sur cette
question de trouver des majorités parce
que depuis le début et oui mais vous
avez pu constater que depuis le début du
quinquennat il y a eu 23 textes
d'adopter que ce soit d'origine
parlementaire ou d'origine du
gouvernement sur ces 23 textes 20 ont
été adoptés en ayant une majorité plus
large que la majorité présidentielle
donc vous voyez bien qu'on peut agir
même si à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons une majorité que relative nous
sommes à 40 députés de la majorité
absolue et depuis le début du
quinquennat fin de texte ont été adoptés
en allant chercher des députés d'autres
groupes que les groupes de la majorité
présidentielle et c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que nous allons continuer à
travailler œuvrer et d'ailleurs une fois
la procédure de de parlementaire sur la
réforme des retraites il y a eu un vote
sur les Jeux Olympiques avec le projet
loi JO dans la foulée comme le vote sur
le nucléaire vous voyez que ça ne je
crois que ça ne change pas
fondamentalement
la méthode de ce point de vue là qui
vise à aller chercher des majorités plus
larges et puis en ce qui concerne la
dissolution c'est dans les mains du
Président de la République si le moment
venu il estime que c'est nécessaire et
il prendra cette décision là ça c'est la
solution pour vous mais solution à quoi
le processus de politique pour trouver
des majorités n'est pas bloqué je vous
le rappelle je viens de vous dire qu'on
a un projet loi Jo un projet loi
nucléaire qui a été voté donc il y a il
y a pas un blocage de l'Assemblée
nationale ou du Sénat c'est une
démission que le Président de la
République a donné à Elisabeth borne de
tenter d'élargir la majorité on se
demande un petit peu vers qui l'élargir
quelques personnalités DLR à gauche ça a
l'air bloqué comment vous imaginez les
choses aujourd'hui comment est-ce que ça
va continuer se faire par des
négociations de personnes à personne sur
chaque texte mais vous savez on a une
méthode qui a fonctionné sur la plupart
des textes
si on peut aller plus loin dans une
structure avec des partenaires nous le
ferons et puis sinon continuera projet
par projet à essayer à projet de loi par
projet de loi texte par textes de
trouver des majorités est-ce que ça peut
passer par un remaniement par exemple
qui intègrerait certaines personnalités
DLR du à gauche et qui permet d'élargir
et d'asseoir cette moi qui vais vous
parler du remaniement c'est les la
responsabilité du Président de la
République et de la première ministre
sur la manière de faire les textes ce
que l'ordre du jour de évite cette
semaine il va y avoir le texte
immigration il a été retiré Emmanuel
Macron a dit qu'il aurait sans doute
plusieurs textes et qu'ils arriveront
dans les prochaines semaines est-ce que
là-dessus vous pouvez nous en dire plus
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
première ministre en lien avec les
chambres en lien avec les groupes
politiques elle a alors on a rencontré
certains de l'Assemblée nationale lundi
il y aura tout une séquence et une
séance de rencontre avec les groupes
politiques avec les différents acteurs
du Parlement pour
bien sûr avec les membres du gouvernant
pour définir une feuille de route avec
des sommes de priorité qui ces priorités
se traduiront à la fois par des actions
dans le cadre de la politique publique
qui est menée par les administrations
par les ministères en lien avec
collectivités territoriale en lien avec
les administrations des concentrés de
l'État et puis il y aura une partie
aussi liée à l'actualité parlementaire
il y a l'action publique du gouvernement
et de l'État ne se résume pas à l'action
parlementaire bien évidemment
il y aura donc un certain nombre de
priorités qui seront définis avec un
calendrier de textes qui sera présenté
et notamment les priorités à court terme
ce qui est certain c'est que
l'immigration est et notamment le texte
qui était dans les tuyaux est une
priorité on voit bien qu'il y a il y a
un besoin de répondre à un certain
nombre de problématiques de
simplification de démarche de
facilitation de procédures et donc c'est
évidemment ça fait ça fait non mais je
vais pas vous dire quel est le
calendrier
parlementaire
non j'ai pas dit à court terme je dis
que c'est une priorité force
vous voulez des réponses alors même que
le processus de consultation pour
pouvoir définir ce calendrier et même et
pas fini vous voulez ce qu'on appelle
mettre la charrue avant les boeufs donc
les sons la première ministre finir ses
consultations il y aura ensuite une une
feuille de route qui sera à présent en
lien avec le prix en la République et
dans cette veuve de route il y aura une
partie parlementaire dans lequel il y
aura un agenda qui sera fixé donc pour
les semaines
de la République
et on s'est pas décidé sur le calendrier
c'est pas décidé sur ce qui sera le
contenu de ce processus calendrier et
vous avez fixer une deadline dans les
semaines qui viennent
pas d'un texte aussi sonner avec une
partie Darmanin une partie du socle pour
schématiser un peu est-ce que c'était
l'objectif du fait de reporter ce texte
de le saucissonner de faire une partie
gauche une partie droite
il y a simplement la volonté de dire
prenons le temps de réfléchir de
discuter d'échanger et de voir quels
sont les priorités à court moyen et long
terme Edward de quelle manière ça se
traduit d'un point de vue législatif
donc en ce qui concerne l'immigration
verra quels sont on peut pas nous dire
d'un côté il faut faire des textes plus
courts c'est trop compliqué on y arrive
pas et en même temps éventuellement
reprocher de faire des textes plus
courts tout en gardant évidemment une
cohérence d'ensemble moi j'entends le
message du Sénat qui dit attention on
peut pas sur des sujets aussi importants
perdre une cohérence d'ensemble pour une
compréhension globale de sujets mais ça
je le comprends très très bien après
comment ça se traduit en termes de
textes de loi de contribution des
parlementaires à travers des
propositions de loi tout ça n'est pas
encore définitif évidemment
passer par le Parlement pour
pour faire des textes comment est-ce que
vous pouvez faire alors faire des textes
sans le Parlement ça c'est pas possible
il faut expliquer à nos compatriotes qui
le comprennent très bien que l'action
publique de l'État en particulier du
l'exécutif et du gouvernement c'est pas
simplement par faire passer des projets
lois au Parlement qui ne veut pas dire
contourner le Parlement ça veut dire
bien expliquer à nos compatriotes que
l'action de l'État c'est aussi ce que
font les administrations dans les
départements dans les régions comme on
peut mieux mettre en avant expliquer
mieux peut-être coordonné mais rendre
plus efficace l'action de l'État dans
ces missions hors du Parlement mais ce
qui veut pas dire
incontournement du Parlement et pas du
tout pas du tout c'est la vérité je veux
dire l'action publique de l'État ne
passe pas tout le temps spécifiquement
sur la loi heureusement
quand il y a je sais pas trois ou quatre
projets lois dans une année ou dans une
dans un semestre au Parlement
heureusement qu'on continue de
travailler sur tous les autres sujets et
c'est peut-être là où il faut qu'on
améliore les choses pour rendre plus
visible plus efficace l'action publique
avec des attentes de nos compatriotes en
matière de santé en matière d'éducation
en matière de transition écologique en
matière d'ordre en matière de de
réindustrialisation et qui passe
évidemment pas éventuellement par des
lois mais aussi par une action publique
déterminée en lien avec les
administrations en lien avec les
collectivités territoriales et tous les
acteurs de la vie publique et faire
passer plus de réformes de cette manière
là que par le Parlement on voit que
finalement les choses s'enlissent quand
même souvent assez longtemps
moi je suis moins sévère que vous sur
l'action du Parlement ça n'enise pas les
textes
ont depuis le début du quinquennat dans
une configuration politique inédite
c'est la première fois depuis le début
de la cinquième République qui a une
majorité relative avec 40 députés de la
majorité absolue pour autant on voit
bien qu'il y a pas de majorité
alternative on l'a bien vu c'est le
rassemblement des contraires entre la
France insoumise et le rassemblement
national ça ne peut pas gouverner pays
on voit donc il faut bien continuer
d'agir et d'agir on l'a vu depuis le
début d'un assez possible et cette
action elle doit continuer d'être au
Parlement mais doit être aussi peut-être
mieux mis en valeur et plus efficace
dans l'action des administrations des
actions des ministères sur le terrain
dans les départements il y a un accord
qui a été trouvé il y a quelques
semaines entre les partenaires sociaux
sur le partage de la valeur est-ce qu'il
y aura prochainement un projet de loi ou
une proposition de loi sur ce sujet il y
a une volonté effectivement de
transcrire rapidement dans la loi cet
accord la première ministre la très
clairement dit c'est ce qu'on doit
regarder dans les dans les jours qui
viennent vous avez vu que l'incerton
nombre de députés de groupes à
l'Assemblée nationale auditionne en ce
moment les organisations syndicales
c'est très bien ça permettra de
contribuer à la réflexion sur ce texte
une proposition et la première ministre
en lien avec la majorité prendra en lien
aussi avec les autres forces politiques
d'opposition constructive la meilleure
façon de de transcrire cet accord qui
est important dans la loi un mot sur le
49-3 parce que les événements a annoncé
qu'il y aurait plus de 49,3 hors-tex
financier est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut inscrire de manière pérenne
dans la Constitution selon vous ce qui
est certain c'est qu'on nous voulons
notre méthode c'est d'aller chercher des
majorités voilà et on a bien vu sur les
textes financiers notamment sur le
projet de loi de finance avant même que
commence le processus parlementaire de
construction de la loi certaines
oppositions ont dit on ne votera pas le
texte on comprend c'est voter un projet
de loi de finance un budget c'est un
marqueur d'appartenance ou pas à
l'opposition ou à la majorité pour
autant il faut bien donner un budget au
pays et donc c'est pour ça
cette méthode où c'est que pour ce
quinquennat
venu des institutions et si c'est ce
point-là mérite d'être d'être
institutions cette constitution elle a
été faite
par ces rédacteurs pour prendre en
compte notamment une partie de ce qui
avait été constaté sous la Quatrième
République c'est à dire l'incap capacité
pour le pays d'agir de se réformer faute
de stabilité parlementaire et bien il y
a un moment donné où la Constitution
permet un certain nombre de choses et
notamment le 49-3 d'adopter des textes
tout en prenant une responsabilité celle
de faire tomber son gouvernement je
rappelle que quand même ils avaient de
bornes elle a pris sa responsabilité vu
l'importance du texte de éventuellement
être démissionné ou renversé s'il y
avait eu une majorité de députés pour le
faire il y a pas eu de majorité pour le
faire dernière question dernière
question vous évoquiez ce qui s'est
passé assez de Soline ce week-end un
plan où va être annoncé demain par le
gouvernement est-ce que la construction
de nouvelles megames fait partie de ce
plan haut et ce qu'il va y avoir un
moratoire sur ce sujet et vous verrez
demain quelles seront les annonces sur
le plan o du gouvernement
la charrue avant
merci Franck on regarde la Une de La
Dépêche du Midi
magnifique